well I am I'm pretty blown away honestly
by what I just witnessed I'm coming from
the rally here in Philly the rally that
as I'm sure you're aware of the genesis
of it by now but just to review Brian
Sims the Democratic state lawmaker here
at Philadelphia had been harassing and
costing pro-lifers and and filming
himself doing it proudly so we decided
to hold a rally in support of the the
victims of his bullying and in defense
most importantly of the unborn and as I
said I'm just coming from the rally and
the turnout was incredible I mean
hundreds of people Street was packed
there was barely room to stand people
came from all over I personally talked
to people who came from Texas California
Ohio all up and down the East Coast I
talked to one guy he drove in from
Oklahoma basically drove through the
night to be here on and on and of course
there were a lot of a lot of local
people here as well hundreds and
hundreds of people and you know what I
was most excited about is that a lot of
people that I talked to afterwards told
me that they had never attended an event
like this they had never been to a
pro-life event before I heard that from
a lot of people and so there were there
were plenty of pro-life veterans plenty
of AK activists you know people who do
this kind of thing all the time which is
great but there was also a sizable
number of people who have never stood
outside of a clinic they've never done
this never participated in something
like this and I'm I'm grateful for that
and I hope that it's in what many of
those people told me is that this is
they planned for this to be the first of
many such events that they will attend I
hope that is the case in fact CBS
reported that over I was wondering what
the I didn't get a head count myself but
as far as the official I don't have an
official crowd size number CBS this says
that there were over a thousand people
and in fact I'll let me I'll play their
report their reports that they did on
the rally just to give you an idea of
the size and also because honestly I'm
kind of shocked at the local CBS
affiliate
first of all they sent the helicopter to
get a look at the crowd and then they
accurately reported the size of the
crowd which I'm impressed by so here's
their report Sims has received
widespread condemnation for the incident
let's take you live now to that rally on
the ground with Eyewitness News reporter
Greg Argos good afternoon Greg
good afternoon there Janelle and Jim
yeah more than a thousand people have
gathered here in front of the Planned
Parenthood clinic 1/12 and locust tree
take a live look of just how many folks
are out here right now most of these
folks are part of the pro-life movement
they're calling for an end to abortion
but they're gathering here today because
of two videos posted by an elected state
official now the two videos went viral
this week but state representative Brian
Sims recorded them in April one video
shows Sims approaching three teens and a
mother prayerfully protesting in front
of the clinic he offers money to anyone
who can identify the teens the second
nearly nine minute video follows an
elderly woman she's also praying outside
of the Planned Parenthood clinic here
Sims calls the woman racist and says
she's an old white lady now back here
live if we take a look from our chopper
you can see just how large of this crowd
is the videos received widespread
criticism as you can imagine from both
sides of the abortion debate and this
week live action a pro-life organization
called for a rally outside the clinic
the crowd gathering here this morning
calling for state Rep Sims to resign and
praying for those working and entering
the facility a heavy police presence
surrounds this building and at least a
dozen Planned Parenthood volunteers
stood guard outside to help advocate or
help escort I should say anyone inside
the building most gathered here say this
shows the power of the pro-life movement
we also did speak with one woman who was
pro-choice take a listen to both sides
it shows the strength of the pro-life
community that the purlins community
here in Philadelphia and Beyond will not
back down to violence bullying and
intimidation we were overwhelmed just
with the success of our fundraiser where
people were giving their own money in
five and ten and twenty five dollar
increments but the
people showed up I know some people here
traveled from such incredible distances
to be here it is it means so much to me
and to my family I'm out here to provide
support for the volunteers that are
coming to help people get services that
they need I wanted to just make sure
that it felt like they felt safe and
back here live you can just see how
large this crowd is it's basically
closed down Locust Street between 12th
and 11th Street here in Center City a
heavy police presence and if we look to
the left here you can see some of the
volunteers from Planned Parenthood
they're wearing the smocks the orange
and pink smocks helping everyone or
anyone who needs to enter the clinic
here get through now a lot of folks have
called for representative Sims to resign
he has not made any direct statement
other than a video here at least two
days ago calling his actions aggressive
but he's not stated anything since that
is the latest live here in Center City
that is uh that's a that's a pretty big
pretty big crowd I would have been happy
honestly with a hundred people showing
up and when I sent a tweet this all
started with a tweet that I sent on
Monday night where I said it it'd be
great if we had a rally there you know
if a bunch of pro lifers showed up to in
response to all this bullying and five
days later there you go with over a
thousand people packing the street as I
said if a hundred people came originally
I was thinking maybe we get a hundred
people and and that would be good I'd be
I would been happy with that I wasn't
expecting anything like that and so that
shows you you know it shows you a few
things but it shows you that social
media can Twitter is a godforsaken
hellscape most of the time and it's a
time suck most of the time and it's
destroying our lives in many ways but it
can be used for good and that's where
this pretty much this entire event was
organized just through not just me but
many pro lifers and conservatives and
with you know a platform tweeting about
it and getting people out so this was
this pretty much this is a grass roots
or organically organized through social
media mainly through Twitter and that
you good so it is a tool that can be
used for good and and I think we should
try to do that more often if I did have
one complain about the event it's this
moment right here look at this picture
you see Lila's that's a lot of rows
there and you see her face the
expression she's making now of course I
get that face a lot when I talk I'm very
used to it you know I get that face for
when I'm tweeting I assume that people
read my tweets with that look on their
face I get that look at my wife a lot
from all my family and loved ones I'm
I'm used to that face but that was
actually see she's making that face
there because I when I first got to the
podium
Lila tried to get me to take off my
sunglasses because she said it was
cloudy and rainy at the time so there's
no reason to have them on and I refused
to take them off why did I refuse
because they're prescription sunglasses
and I'd be blind without them so Lila
you know arguably is discriminating
against the visually impaired there and
which is which is terribly terrible
honestly after that moment I had to keep
the sunglasses on to hide my tears that
I was shedding because I was so wounded
by this discriminatory attack you might
say that I could have worn regular
glasses and that's true but then what if
the Sun peeks out from the clouds
suddenly and melts my eyeballs and that
does happen I mean happens all the time
to people I've heard of it happening so
so there's that but aside from that one
little hiccup it was a remarkable and
inspiring motivating all-around awesome
event and in all seriousness aside from
the sunglass shaming Lila Rose and the
people at live-action deserve a ton of
credit after I had this idea on Twitter
I immediately got in touch with
live-action because I know that if
anyone could throw this together in four
or five days it would be them and they
did and they you know they had to do
quite a bit till you got to get the
permits you got to get all the equipment
organized the speaker's gets up you know
it's organ coordinate with the local
pro-life leaders of law enforcement is a
lot you got to do and they had four or
five days to do it and and they did it
now people have been asking me if Brian
Sims showed up and
of course no he didn't he did not show
up there was a little chance that he
would I would have loved to see him I
would have loved for him to come but I
didn't expect that he would Sims is a
pariah now to Planned Parenthood perhaps
even more than he is in the pro-life
movement I think I think Planned
Parenthood probably hates him more now
than they do us because I'm sure they
blame him for the fact that a thousand
pro-lifer showed up to their front you
know we're standing in their front yard
well not really in the front yard we
were on public property but they the
fact that there were a thousand pro
lifers outside of their building they
blame him for that
not without reason and so he was never
going to shut a show up and not only
that but it's it's not just that Sims
didn't come there were also almost no
counter protesters which which did not
surprise me either
that isn't surprising there never are
very many who come to these kinds of
things they don't show up to the March
for life or any other pro-life event
even if you think well this is the kind
of thing where you like where is aunt
Eva isn't this what auntie was made for
is that show up it's something like this
I didn't expect them to come and they
didn't why is that well I think there
are two reasons one they don't want to
engage right they can't defend their
position and they know it so they pick
on the weak and the vulnerable they pick
on they're like you know lions who are
looking for the weak injured gazelle too
separated from the pack to go after and
I'm being way too flattering to them
comparing them to lions because they're
not at all maybe hyenas or something
we've been better comparison but they
they're looking they they'll come after
you if you're by yourself and if they
think that you're not going to be able
to that if they think you you won't be
able to or won't be willing to defend
yourself so Brian Sims was going after
kids he was going after the the older
woman who would have been perfectly
capable defending herself but she
decided to remain silent which I think
was a which I think was a very good
decision on her part she let him
basically you know dig his own grave as
it were bury himself with his words and
he did so she made the right decision
and that's what they're looking for if
they think that okay they're gonna be
people there who will engage with me and
and argue with me and do so you know
competently well they don't want any
part of that so they're not gonna be
there
the second reason though why why we
didn't see any counter protesters is the
pro-abortion movement you have to
understand is much smaller and much more
lethargic and and that's the fact that
matter now I say the pro-abortion
movement is much smaller than the
pro-life movement yet abortion is still
legal almost everywhere in the country
right so why is that if I'm claiming
that the one movement is so much bigger
than the other well that's because the
vast majority of people are not part of
either movement most people aren't in
any movement at all they're they're not
interested in moving one trishna or
another they just want to sit back and
and float and that's where most people
are the vast majority are indifferent
intellectually lazy and they're kind of
in the middle and that means they're
gonna go with the status quo they're
gonna go with the way that with the just
the direction that the water happens to
be flowing and and so the status quo is
abortion in our society but in terms of
actually getting people and that's that
that's the ACE they have up their sleeve
is that they know that yeah they don't
have an energetic at-large movement but
they also know that most people are just
going to go with whatever they say in
terms of actually getting people
mobilized well they could never do what
we just did in a week they could never
do that I mean I would challenge them to
try but they can't today they're never
gonna do that just like they're never
gonna get a March the size of the March
for Life the most they could do
they had the one woman's Marg but but
they claimed that that was not a
pro-abortion March I was just a March
for women so as far as an expla vent
that explicitly deals with this issue
they're not gonna do anything like what
we did today or what the march of life
does or in many other kinds of similar
events they just can't do it now my
point bringing that up is that this is a
huge advantage that we have that we do
have all the energy on our side we have
the ability and the willingness to
mobilize to get involved and we also
have the truth you know it what we're
defending is life and that really lends
itself yeah it lends itself to a rally
or a march or giving a speech because
what are you putting on the sign you're
so you're putting things on the sign
about life and love and liberty and
that's what we're marching for it's the
kind of thing you could be proud to be a
part of it that's one of the other
reasons that's one of the other problems
that the pro-abortion movement has is
that even people who are sympathetic to
them and even people who otherwise maybe
would be willing to go out and be an
activist a lot of them are embarrassed
and ashamed to be explicitly involved in
this issue on that side of it they don't
want to be they don't want to hold a
sign saying yay abortion right they
don't want that which is why if there's
any hope of actually getting people they
need to say something well it's a
women's March it's not about that it's
about all these other random issues so
sure I'll hold a sign saying yay women
but we're not afraid to address the
actual issue because we're not ashamed
of our position we know that it's right
and it's good and it's just
and that's a huge advantage we have so
my hope is that what happened today is
the beginning of something it's the it's
a tipping point as I said all these
people said I'd never been involved in a
pro-life movement before is it's my
first time well I hope that those people
stay involved and stay active and you
know this isn't as I said this isn't new
for pro-life activists they've been
doing this for a long time so this isn't
new for them but I hope it's it's a new
thing for a lot of people who are
sympathetic to the pro-life cause who
are pro-life but up until this point
they're pro-life in their heads or maybe
on the computer not out in the real
world you see what we did with this
issue what we did it was very simple we
saw something that we didn't like that
was unjust and wrong and we said you
know what we're just gonna show up yeah
we can send tweets and we'll do that and
we can complain and all but we're also
just gonna show we're just gonna go
we're gonna get on our feet you were to
walk there and we're gonna show up yeah
that's what we need to start doing
showing up expressing our point of view
in the real world we need to be doing a
lot more of that nothing wrong with with
complaining about injustice but when
we're complaining about it the next
question is okay what are you gonna do
about it we did something and this modes
might seem like a small thing I don't
know but at the various guy Brian's
hymns he he this was in him harassing
pro-lifers he'd been doing that for a
long time and filming himself doing it
for a long time the only difference is
that we finally put our foot down and
said you know what no we're not gonna
let you do this anymore you're gonna pay
a price for that
all right what else here's something let
me see if I can pull it up an Australian
school renamed mother's day calling it
acknowledgement day acknowledgement day
as the principal stated we no longer
subscribe to a binary world this is from
reading from the daily water now as the
Daily Mail writes of Brunswick East
primary school in Melbourne in previous
years the school has hosted a
fundraising stall where children could
buy Mother's Day merchandise such as
mugs trinkets candles and soaps but now
the stall will be called the
appreciation stall instead where
children can buy gifts for anyone
principal Janet D pilla wrote in the
school newsletter you will see further
in this newsletter a fantastic poster
for our first acknowledgement day we
will be holding two of these days each
year one to coincide with the
traditional Mother's Day and the other
to cook to coincide with the traditional
Father's Day there's been a lot of
discussion about the reason we celebrate
these days in the naming of the
celebration I believe that days like
this are important because we do need to
stop and show gratitude we do need to
stop and show gratitude I sincerely hope
that this change in name will show that
we as a computer you recognize blah blah
blah blah blah okay so it's it's it's
acknowledgment Day Mother's Day you know
I've talked about this plenty as you
know but here's what it comes down to
okay with all this non-binary stuff
transgenderism stuff gender fluidity
stuff here's here's the point here's the
question really it's a simple question
what is a woman what is a woman very
simple question what is a woman can you
define the word you need to be able to
define it I can so as a believer in
biology
I confess I do believe that biology is a
thing that it exists so as I believe in
biology I can define
I would say that a woman in principle is
a female of the human species who
possesses two X chromosomes and female
reproductive organs as well as dozens of
other or even hundreds of other
biological markers distinct to the
female subset of the human species that
that's how I would define the term and
and this will be the case for every
female barring sickness mutation or
injury so there are going to be a few
exceptions but you know for instance
women who don't have female reproductive
organs not because they have a
functioning male reproductive organs but
just because they've some sort of
mutation or there could have been a
sickness I mean but if it is an
exception it's because something has
gone wrong physically and that's very
clear so there you go that's how I
define it if you don't define the word
that way then how do you define it after
all if you're going to say that a man
can be a woman then you must be able to
define what both of those words mean
because otherwise it's nonsense
president to say that so-and-so can be a
woman or is a woman okay well what is
that what do you what are you trying to
say he is now I pose this challenge on
Twitter yesterday I spent much of
yesterday trying to get someone to
answer this question like some leftists
it just it's it's if this is a gotcha
question for you then that should tell
you something about your point of view
this should not be a gotcha question all
I'm saying is you're using this word
what do you mean by it tell me that and
we can proceed with the conversation so
I posed this a challenge on Twitter I
said here's a simple challenge for
everyone who thinks that a biological
male can be a woman to find woman I
think any definition will either rule
out the possibility of men being women
or expand the concept of womanhood into
utter meaninglessness prove me wrong go
ahead all right so there you go hey
there's a challenge someone step up to
the plate some leftist and give me a
definition and and then we can go from
there but going through the responses
there was almost a
read responses and no one someone says
why don't you mind your own business
okay that's not a response it how am I
not minding my own business I'm just
saying what's what's what's the
definition of this work when someone
asks for the definition of a word if
someone you know if your kids said to
you you know daddy what what does what
is what does this word mean would you
say mind your own business I mean I'm a
human being and so words are part of my
business too so mind your business
someone says someone says a woman is a
classification of human beings that we
make in society it's ultimately
arbitrary okay so their definition is
there's no definition it doesn't mean
anything
all right well that's not really
answering the question but if that's the
case then you understand that it makes
no sense for you to say so-and-so is a
woman or for someone to say I am a woman
you realize that that that phrase now
means nothing and so if I'm supposed to
respect whether that they identify as a
whit was a woman you have to respect
that well why do I have to respect it it
doesn't you just said it doesn't mean
anything they may as well identify as a
you know as a who Billy Moo it's just
it's a made-up word you're saying
definitions are problematic and we're
invented by the patriarchy to oppress
minorities well I you know I assume
that's sarcastic but I have no idea at
this point
yeah there's I I go through all these
but no one is able to give a definition
no one from a woman okay that here's a
definition a woman is someone who
identifies as a woman that's it it's
really simple okay so your definition of
woman is someone who identifies as woman
your definition of table is a thing that
is a table your definition of Apple is a
thing that is an apple is it that's not
definition you can't use the word you're
defining in the definition because that
still leaves the question of okay well
what does that word mean that you're
just used in the definition if if I were
on if I were on the left-wing persuasion
this would trouble me it would it would
trouble me that a simple word like woman
that I use all the time I can't define
because I know that if I define it
my whole worldview will shatter you
should be troubled by that all right
let's go to some emails before we wrap
things up for the day Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from from hope says hey Matt
I've been following for a while and
don't always agree with your views but I
appreciate your passion for the pro-life
cause I might be wrong but I don't feel
I've heard you talk much about how to
act towards women who are in a position
to make the choice I was a pregnant
teenager who's surrounded by a lot of
people from church who are more
judgmental than they were supportive it
was extremely lonely and scary abortion
was never on the table for me but I
believe a lot of these women feel forced
because they want to avoid the judgment
there seems to be a lot of focus on how
awful abortion is which is fine I just
feel like there should be more focus on
caring for these girls and applauding
the choice to keep their babies not
applauding the situation or the choice
to get pregnant but showing love and
grace what do you think oh I totally
agree and and it will please you to
learn that there are a lot of people the
probably movement that this is the this
this is what they do they offer support
and encouragement to women pregnancy
centers there are pregnancy centers in
every city of every major city in
America and and plenty of non major
cities as well and this is what they do
they reach out to the women they offer
help and counseling and guidance and
love and acceptance and a lot of
practical things to like will help you
with diapers will get you clothes will
you know
every practice centers will help women
in any possible way there was I did a
fundraiser for a pregnancy center down
in Florida recently and they had some
volunteers from the center had built a
house for a pregnant woman who was
homeless so I mean you know they that
does happen but I agree with you that
that's a really important part of this
discussion and I will also say that when
we're talking about this issue or any
issue the way that we talk about it will
depend in large part on who we're
talking to and in what the context is
now there is never a context where we
should lie there is never a context
where we should encourage people to do
the wrong thing but there can be
situations where it calls for a more
gentle approach we're using certain
words and certain phrases wouldn't be
helpful and if you're talking to a woman
who's in a desperate situation who's
scared doesn't know what to do who has
no support around her well that's
someone who needs as you say for you to
reach out show love show acceptance
avoid anything that reeks of judgment
that's gonna be the approach you need
there while still remaining firmly
grounded in the truth so you can never
compromise on that but the way that you
communicate that truth will will shift
sometimes depending on who you're
talking to and what the what the
situation is when we're talking about
this issue on a on the public stage and
we're talking about it generally then I
think that calls for a much more
straightforward blunt approach because
they're trying to cut through the noise
cut through the haze speak to people in
their indifference
and kind of doused some cold water on
them to wake them up but not every
situation is like that and when it's a
more personal one-on-one thing then
maybe you change your approach a little
bit alright this is from Kim I got a lot
of emails on this issue so I'll just
I'll read just one we talked about this
earlier in the week we talked about the
issue of kids in church and what do you
do about kids that are loud in church
and and and all of that so this is from
Kenna says hello Matt I am deeply
annoyed by the comments about children
in Mass those comments are everything
that's wrong with Catholic fellowship
here in America children need to be in
Mass we need to norm normalize worship
for them from a young age we hear all
the time that practice makes perfect
children will not learn how to act in
Mass if they aren't given the
opportunity to be a part of the mass
often we make mass a dreadful experience
for kids when it's just a place where
they were yelled at scolded expected to
sit still in choir for 45 minutes are
you going to church it's only 45 minutes
let me know I'd like to go there it is
no I'm kidding sort of it's especially
frustrating because that is not how
Jesus acts towards children in the
Gospels Jesus is very open and loving
the children let the children come to me
he says I have three children aged three
two and one we carry a lot of quote
joyful noise wherever we go we have a
lot of joyful noise - in our family
although it's you know I must admit
sometimes the noise is less joyful than
others but it's a lot of noise anyway
from experience the only people who have
problems with children are people who
aren't parents I even bring my children
to daily Mass and the little old lady's
love that were there I can remember
before I was mom feeling like young
children who are loud or distracted or
just misbehaving but now that I'm a
mother I totally get that
no two-year-old can developmentally act
like an adult at Mass or anywhere else
it doesn't matter how well-behaved this
two-year-old is in any other setting the
serious problem with this is is allowing
a Catholic Church where children are
made to feel unwelcome if children are
unwelcome then young families are
unwelcome if young families are
unwelcome then who will be the future of
the church this contributes to the
issues that the church is having with
losing American Catholics I an Hispanic
American when I go to spanish-speaking
masses those masses are
with families were so warm to children
there's no expectation that children are
going to remain quiet and seated and no
one is fazed by that we as a church have
to stop being so strict about the
meaning of reverence when it comes to
small children obviously older children
are different once children reached the
age of reason are preparing for first
communion then they must start to have
true reverence and attention to the
whole mass okay and she goes on for that
I have to cut for time a little bit but
that's but yeah I mean it makes a good
point I don't disagree with that we do
have to be accepting of children in in
society in general this is what we're
talking about here today right accepting
children and especially in church I
agree there too and that's one of the
reasons I don't like ice I don't not a
big fan of things like children's church
or you know some churches we ferry the
kids off to some other place I think
they need to be with their parents be
with their family be a they're a part of
the body of Christ right they need to
feel like it so I agree with that but
that's that's fine right we can make
that statement
shield Rijn should be accepted and
welcomed absolutely but also I would
assume you agree there can come a point
where a child is simply being disruptive
to a point that it's unacceptable
because it just makes it impossible for
everyone else to do what they came there
to do so it's great for your child to be
included it's not great if your child's
inclusion means that whatever he's
included in becomes all about him
because of how disruptive and loud he's
being I mean obviously if a kid is
sitting in church literally screaming
then the only thing anyone can hear is
that and so now everything is about him
and that's not okay yeah he should be
included but you can't expect us to up
for us all to simply go along patiently
and
with acceptance with all of your kids
various moods and everything and
whatever he wants to do we have to
simply deal with it
you can't expect that either and I don't
think you would expect that I think you
would agree I hope you would agree there
are most parents understand that but
there are parents who seem to think that
mike is gonna act however he wants and
if he's a distraction you have to deal
with it and if everything becomes about
him okay that's just the way it is and
that's not that's wrong to everybody
else it's also wrong for the child
because the child needs to learn how to
be a part of things but that's not being
a part when you're making everything
about you
a two-year-old can't help but do that
but we as parents have to offer that
loving correction right so I think
there's a balance there that can be
struck finally this is from Joey says
well the subject subject line of the
email is should men wear beards says
dear master of the known universe I was
listening to your podcast and thought of
a verse and Corinthians does not even
nature itself teach you that if a man
have long hair is a shame unto Him first
Corinthians my question is does this
verse apply to beards too and if so
should we all shave ours please forgive
this heresy when you come into your
power Joey I am I am it's no big deal
don't be concerned but I am keeping a
list of people who when I in dictator of
the country will you know be questioned
and probably imprisoned and so see Joey
last name okay so you're you've just
you've made the list with that question
and so congratulations I won't I won't
even dignify it with an answer should we
all shave our beards that you would even
insult me with such a question is all
the more reason for you to have made my
my list alright we'll leave it there
hope you all have a great weekend
Godspeed